[Music]
hello everyone i'm jose tsujimoto
producer on the monster hunter series
and i'm yoshitake suzuki the director on
monster hunter rise sun break first
let's have a look at the new trailer
enjoy
[Music]
these creatures
consume life
those who let themselves be lured into
the trap
will be whisked away by a sweet game the
embodiment of darkness
as they are slowly drained of their life
the darkness will show itself
on my honor as a knight i
[Music]
a worthy adversary indeed
[Music]
sorry to keep you waiting we must bring
peace back
here
[Music]
degrees
this is going to hurt
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
who could have imagined that one day you
and i would go hunting together
going on a quest with you two is gonna
be fun
[Music]
[Music]
monster hunter rise sun break is a
massive expansion to monster hunter rise
it's slated for release on june 30th
2022.
[Music]
a new story will unfold at a new base
with new locales monsters actions and
the addition of the master rank allowing
you to delve even further into the world
of monster hunter rise
[Music]
now i'll pass the baton to mr suzuki to
tell you more about the trailer you just
saw
thank you let's have a look at the
footage again and i'll provide some
extra info as we go along
let's start with the new monsters
first off we have ceregios the flagship
monster of monster hunter 4 ultimate
sergios is characterized by the sharp
blades on its legs which it uses to
attack enemies by diving down on them
from the sky
it also sheds sharp scales called blade
scales
some of its attacks will cause the
bleeding status on the hunter so extreme
caution is advised
the designers were very meticulous in
how ceregio stores and unfolds its
scales and horns so we hope you pay
extra attention to that as well
next let's have a look at two new
subspecies of monsters that appeared in
rise
first we have aurora sondikam
it releases a perpetual cold air to
freeze things around it and even slide
around on the ice to attack hunters
the normal species attacked with a sleep
inducing powder but this subspecies
exhales a powerful ice breath
next up there's magma almadron
it lives in the lava caverns and when it
digs into the ground it adopts a red hue
indicating that it's in a special heated
state
it also uses the magma on its tail to
attack its prey
we've also added new actions for the
hunter as well as more powerful master
ranked versions of the monsters that
appeared in rise
for instance acne-sam now has a backstep
and somersault attack to give it even
more combo potential
and t-rex can now combo from a bite into
a spin attack
if you thought you were already used to
fighting these monsters and rise there
are quite a few surprises in store for
you
moving on let's take a look at the
flagship monster for this game who also
made an appearance in today's trailer
mauzino
malzaino is a fearsome elder dragon who
has brought fearing's kingdom to the
brink of ruin many times in the past it
commands mysterious creatures that it
uses to capture monsters and absorb
their energy
it displays both a certain sense of
beauty and elegance as well as vicious
cruelty when it catches its prey and
consumes their life force
it fights hunters with a variety of
attacks so it's incredibly dangerous
some of its attacks will cause the blood
blight status as well
if a hunter succumbs to blood blight
they enter a battle of life force with
malzino which they must overcome to
survive
it's said that if zeno manages to absorb
a hunter's life force it evolves into an
even more powerful form
it's very risky but definitely worth
seeing with your own eyes
malzino's design was based first and
foremost on a vampire motif
it being an elder dragon we had to
figure out what kind of calamity it
would cause and the designers
incorporated elements of aristocracy
nobility grandeur and cunningness into
their concept arts
based on that
we hammered out further details which
resulted in the current design
the elements i just mentioned are woven
into its theme music as well
the composer managed to turn it into a
really cool song so please give it a
listen in the game
all right time to go i'm proud to join
you on your quest
now let's talk about followers
[Music]
in sun break some quests allow you to
take story characters known as followers
along with you to hunt together
these follower quests are single player
only so we hope you'll have fun running
around the locales with your favorite
characters
each follower has their own weapon
specialization
during quests they'll recover your
health place traps and sometimes even
ride monsters so they're very useful to
bring along
you'll gradually unlock more characters
to pick from as you advance in the game
for the characters from elgato you'll be
able to take fioren lucika j
admiral galius and master arlo with you
as for kamura you'll be able to bring
along several characters in addition to
hinoa and minoto who already made their
appearance
these colorful characters are sure to
make your hunts even more fun and you
can even earn exclusive rewards so make
sure you try them out
now let's move on to the new player
actions
ryze introduced various new gameplay
elements like the wire bug and wyvern
riding
sunbreak will expand on these elements
even further with more features and
tweaks
let's have a look at the new switch
skill swap function first
this game adds a variety of new switch
skills including new silk bind attacks
you'll now be able to swap between
different sets of switch skills on the
fly using the new switch skill swap
function
[Music]
you can register two loadouts in advance
so you can use two sets of switch skills
during your quests
this lets you combo silk bind attacks
and gain their synergized effects
swapping sets at the right moment and
making the most out of every situation
allows more freedom and creativity in
your play style
now let's say you need to avoid a
monster attack or distant yourself from
a monster while swapping skill sets
that's where the swap evade comes in
swap evade lets you quickly change your
position while swapping sets
switch skill swap and swap evade will
give you a lot more freedom when moving
around the battlefield
we've also added a wide variety of
tweaks
for instance you can now go into a wall
run without using a wire dash first and
you can pick whether to ride a monster
or keep attacking it when it's in a
mountable state
there are various options to change the
original controls to new controls
there's even more new tweaks like that
but we'll tell you more about that at a
later date we plan to release
introduction videos for the new silk
bind attacks and switch skills for all
14 weapons according to the schedule
shown on screen
we hope you look forward to how these
new silk bind attacks and the switch
skill swap are going to change the
action in sunbreak
we've also got some new short clips for
sunbreak that'll teach you some new
useful tips for your hunts
[Music]
make sure to follow the official twitter
account so you don't miss out
that's all we have to share regarding
the new gameplay elements today
hope you enjoyed it
[Music]
now let's have a look at the product
information for monster hunter rise sun
break
if you already own the physical version
or the digital version of monster hunter
rise and you just want to buy monster
hunter rise sun break all you'll need is
the digital version of monster hunter
rise sun break
[Music]
for the digital version we are also
offering the monster hunter rise sun
break deluxe edition which includes
add-on content
there will also be a monster hunter rise
plus sun breaks set including both the
main game and the expansion for players
who want to start monster hunter rise
from the beginning
[Music]
all of these versions include special
purchase bonuses so grab them while you
can
the exclusive bonuses are layered armor
for your pelico and palomute
make sure to pre-order the game so you
don't miss out
we will also be releasing three new
amiibo for monster hunter rise sunbreak
[Music]
each of these amiibo unlocks a special
layered armor
we've also got some news about
peripherals
a monster hunter rise sun break edition
of the nintendo switch pro controller
will be made available
this is a special version of the
nintendo switch pro controller with a
mousino design on the front
all of this product information is also
available on the official website
the digital version of monster hunter
rise sun break is now available for
pre-order
we hope you check it out
if you have saved data of monster hunter
stories 2 wings of ruin you'll be able
to unlock the navaroo costume layered
armor for your pelico in monster hunter
rise sun break
[Music]
of course you'll also be able to use the
rider series hunter layered armor and
the taquino costume that are unlockable
in monster hunter rise
[Music]
that's all of the news for now
to reiterate monster hunter rise sun
break will be released worldwide on june
30th 2022.
[Music]
we will also be releasing several free
title updates after that
we'll have more to share with you on the
free updates and other new info around
june so there's a lot to look forward to
[Music]
thank you for tuning in to today's
special monster hunter rise sun break
digital event
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you